[موسيقى]
السنتين الاخرانيين شفنا على الاقل 15
قانون اتغيروا على الاطار الاقليمي ويمكن
12 دوله شافت قوانينها اتغيرت مجرد في 24
شهر الاخيره دول طبعا في دول عندها قوانين
قويه جدا جدا ضد العنف ضد المراه من زمان
من الخمسينات ومن الستينات من تونس منهم
مصر منهم المغرب بس التغييرات الجديده
شفناها عامه في الخليج دول الخليجيه منها
بحرين الامارات السعوديه فهي المشكله طبعا
الكبيره في التنفيذ
والتنفيذ يعني ايه يعني حتى لو في قانون
اتغير في دوله معينه يا ترى البوليس عارف
ازاي يتعامل بالقانون الجديد ده يا ترى
الجامعات الاهليه اللي هي بتساعد المراه
اللي هي باقي مثلا انها تتعامل بالقانون
الجديد ده وهنا طبعا شايفين ان في فروق
كبيره جدا بين
ان احنا نغير القانون بس والناحيه الثانيه
تطبيق القنوات
[موسيقى]
في كذا اولويات طبعا في المنطقه العربيه
منهم التمكين الاقتصادي احنا في عندنا
مشكله والمشكله دي بقى لها يمكن 30 سنه
لورا ان مستوى التعليم او تعليم المراه في
المنطقه العربيه عادي لو قارناها مع دول
تانيه او من مناطق تانيه من اعلى حتى
الناس في لو قريناها بالعالم كويس بس في
نفس الوقت النسبه العاليه دي مش بتعمل
خالص
بالتمكين الاقتصادي اللي احنا شايفينه
يعني المراه في الشغل في شؤون الشغل هنا
تقريبا المراه في الدول العربيه تقريبا
20% من من
بيشتغلوا وده طبعا اقل خالص من العالم
حوالينا
وبالذات ان المراه العربيه متعلمه فاحنا
بنسال نفسنا ليه طبعا في القوانين في
موضوع
في كذا موضوع هنا هو بيصعب على المراه
العربيه
[موسيقى]
والخساره الزياده كمان ان السيده العربيه
النهارده متعلمه اكثر من ومن
مناطق تانيه في مجالات معينه مهمه جدا
بالنسبه لنا النهارده اللي هي الساينس
اللي هي الرياضيات والعلوم احنا عارفين ان
70% من الشغلانات الجديده اللي هتيجي في
الثلاث اربع سنين الجايه هتبقى بالظبط في
الاطار في الاطار ده فده طبعا حلو قوي
للسيده العربيه انها تدخل اطار الشغل
للتمكين الاقتصادي التمكين الاقتصادي
للمراه تمكين الاقتصادي للاسره
الاقتصادي للدوله وعلى اطار اقليمي ككل
[موسيقى]
لما اقتصاد الاسره يبقى مستريح شويه هنا
بتبقى المشاكل والفركشنز والتعب بين الزوج
والزوجه بيقل شويه فهنا حتى العنف بيقل
شويه ما فيش شك برضو ان في ناحيه تانيه
صوره تانيه لو انا عندي تمكينه اقتصادي
هتكون واقفه على رجليا وكمان هقدر ابقى
اقدر اقول انا عايزه ايه انا محتاجه ايه
وهنا كمان يبقى الفامي ممكن تبقى زي ما
بنقول فيها توازن اكثر احنا طبعا كل
العالم دلوقتي طالع من كوفيد في حروب
حوالينا فما فيش شك ان كل العالم شايف نوع
من الذبذبه الاقتصاديه وعايزين نحاول نطلع
منها
زي ما بنقول فهنا التمكينه الاقتصادي
للمراه بالذات لان تعليم المراه او نسبه
تعليم المراه عالي قوي في العالم العربي
دي طبعا اوفرتونيتي قوي بالنسبه للدول
العربيه انها تقدر تطلع من المشكله
الاقتصاديه اللي هي فيها النهارده
[موسيقى]